bonjour un son chaud mais merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct dans
la matinale de rtl france un nouveau
conseil de défense et est prévue
aujourd'hui
il est peut-être questions de
renforcement de restrictions sanitaires
avec une territorialisation des mesures
notamment face à la flambée de cas en
paca dans le grand est et en bourgogne
franche comté ain
c'est votre région qu'en pensez-vous de
cette territorialisation est ce que
c'est une bonne idée
oui moi je pense que c'est une bonne
idée il faut regarder là où les cas sont
les plus présents mais en aucune manière
cela doit passer par les maires je vois
beaucoup d'appels que ce soit des
collègues de nancy maire socialiste ou
ceux de chalon sur saône par exemple
républicain qui voudrait que les maires
décident eux mêmes est la santé en
français les nationales gouvernement
peut décider territorialisées mais ce
n'est pas à nous élus locaux qui ne
sommes pas experts dans ce domaine qui
d'ailleurs n'avons pas d'autorité dans
le domaine de la santé ou très
marginalement de décider en tout cas
effectivement en bourgogne franche comté
la ville d'autun en saône-et-loire et
être en bourgogne franche comté on voit
que le plateau est très haut que les
hôpitaux sont relativement plein et qu'
il faut absolument éviter que le jour de
l'an ii conduisent à une nouvelle
flambée épidémique qui fasse monter le
nombre de cas au dessus du nombre de
lits comment est-ce que vous expliquer
justement cette hausse des cas en
bourgogne franche comté est ce que vous
allez un début d'explication
honnêtement on ne sait pas on sait pas
trop peut-être que certains ont été plus
touchés par la première vague ont plus
d'immunité collective peut-être comme la
région parisienne pour ce qui nous
concerne ça peut aller assez vite on est
on a des autoroutes des voies de
communication importantes notamment
l'autoroute du soleil qui traverse la
bourgogne franche comté il ya pu aussi
avoir la proximité avec la suisse les
stations de ski
honnêtement on sait pas trop et même
dans des territoires à ces ruraux comme
le morvan et nous sommes dans le parc
naturel du morvan on voit un taux de
contamination assez élevé et pour
l'instant je n'ai pas eu d'explication
des médecins particulièrement incisive
et crédit pour expliquer notre fort taux
de contamination par rapport à d'autres
régions qui sont moins touchés alors
forte contamination également en paca le
maire de nice hier christian estrosi a
demandé des mesures rapides notamment
concernant la vaccination on l'écouté on
en parle après nous souhaitons que la
campagne de vaccination commence tout de
suite et pas dans huit jours
alors est-ce que selon vous il faudrait
vacciner là où justement la propagation
du virus est forte ou pas qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
je crois que la vaccination elle a
commencé d'ailleurs dijon et chalon sur
saône en bourgogne franche comté sont
des sites un peu pilotes
elle doit se mettre en place c'est quand
même toute une chaîne
d'approvisionnement a créé de a à z avec
également une chaîne de contrôle et donc
des comités de pilotage de la
vaccination
et puis une chaîne d'approvisionnement
c'est une chaîne du froid cette chaîne
du grand froid puisqu'il faut des frigos
à moins 80 degrés donc ça se met en
place moi je suis en tant que maire
président du conseil de surveillance de
l'hôpital je suis ces sujets d'autant
qu'on gère certains ehpad
il faut déjà par exemple recueillir le
consentement si dans un ehpad vous avez
aucun consentement ou deux consentement
alors qu'un autre vous en allez avoir
98%
ben finalement peut-être que dans dans
les priorités dans le calendrier en tout
cas vous allez avoir à prioriser
aujourd'hui on en est à recueillir le
consentement a aussi pardonnez-moi
vincent chauvet qu'en est il de ce
consentement qui pose question puisque
les français semblent assez réticent à
cette vaccination
qu'est ce que vous constatez vous dans
les ehpad en ce moment c'est vrai que
c'est assez mitigé
ça dépend souvent de l'avis du médecin
traitant ou de la vie finalement de
l'équipe médicale ou paramédicale qui
est qui autour et qui peut assez
fortement influencé ça dépend de la vie
de la famille puis on a parfois aussi
des personnes âgées atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer ou en phase de quasi
démence ou le consentement et quand même
pas forcément simple
tenir des gens qui ne comprennent pas
finalement qui ne sont pas sortis depuis
plus d'un an qu'ils ne regardent pas les
informations qu'ils ne savent pas ce que
c'est que le virus
donc on va voir je pense que justement
une bonne logistique qui doit permettre
des bons retours d'expérience qui doit
donner confiance dans l'innocuité du
vaccin doit finalement permettre un
meilleur taux de consentement mais on en
est vraiment au début et comme le vaccin
n'est pas obligatoire il faut évidemment
construire cette chaîne logistique
recueillir les consentements et ensuite
procéder à la vaccination on y est on
est au début et je pense qu'on est dans
les temps par rapport à ce que s'était
fixé le gouvernement
mais vincent chauvet vous êtes merde
autant c'est une ville qui abrite un
lycée militaire
je voudrais qu'on parle de ces trois
soldats qui ont été tués au mali hier
une cérémonie d'hommage est prévue
demain la ministre des armées a exprimé
hier soir ses condoléances regarder il
était en mission au mali pour la france
pour le sahel contre le terrorisme
le brigadier-chef cannary maury les
chasseur de 1ère classe d'orient
issakhanian et quentin pocher sont morts
pour la france
mes pensées vont à leurs familles leurs
proches et frères d'armes
la ministre des armées qui a dit que ce
n'était pas le moment de relâcher nos
efforts puisque selon elle notre
stratégie commence à porter ses fruits
ce sont les mots de florence parly qu'en
pensez vous effectivement on a lycée
militaire où sont passé un certain
nombre de militaires français mais aussi
de militaires africains notamment
burkinabé et on a d'ailleurs depuis des
relations importantes avec le burkina
faso est là où les trois militaires sont
tombés hier soir c'était dans cette zone
des trois frontières entre le mali et le
burkina où on voit que des groupes
terroristes déstabilise des sociétés
pour la société burkinabé plutôt
démocratique qu'elle est plutôt bien et
on doit effectivement pas relâcher la
pression
je suis aussi un européen convaincu et
il faut encore plus que jamais faire
monter en puissance et capacité
militaire des pays africains mais
également à impliquer nos partenaires
européens dans dans ce set situation au
sahel qui est qui est extrêmement
compliqué et nous sommes là depuis
presqu'un peu plus d'une dizaine
d'années a essayé d'obtenir des
objectifs qui sont quand même très
complexe dans une zone très vaste et
j'ai une pensée également pour les
familles de ces militaires qui sont
tombé de nouvelles victimes du
terrorisme international et de nos
opérations extérieures en afrique merci
beaucoup vent sont choqués d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions dans la matinale de rtl france